So this first example is a good case for regularization.
The load is mostly evenly distributed, so there is some regular sort of average case that you can shoot for
that'll be relatively easy to predict,
And then occasionally you'll have outliers, and you can do something about them
such as dealing with them separately in another algorithm or on another processor as we discussed before.
So I would consider this a good case for regularization;
it's likely that we can come up with a regularization strategy here that'll work.
On the other hand, when the load varies wildly,
and it's not really easy to predict what is the average case,
you have no idea when you start a process
how long it's going to take or how many items you'll have to process,
then I would say this is not an easy case for regularization,
which is really sort of just restated in the final bullet.
Obviously for regularization,
the whole goal is to extract regular parallelism from irregular parallelism.
So for that point you kind of like you be able to know what is regular,
so if you can predict where and how load and balance is going to take place at run time,
then you can structure the application to deal with the load balancing on the spot.
So unload is relatively evenly distributed.
It's almost regular already and dealing separately with occasional irregularities is likely to work.
If load varies wildly, then it's harder to know what to regularize to,
and it's much easier to regularize the workload if you can predict what that workload is going to be.